la suite du 7 8 avec ce plateau exclusif
des acteurs et des chanteurs vedettes de
stars 80 à la suite de leur passage dans
les Yvelines pour une avant-première
vous les entendrez dans un instant pour
l'instant nous allons faire un point sur
l'actualité du jour
le château de La Coudre à Montigny le
Bretonneux a accueilli pendant plusieurs
années les services de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines depuis le
départ de ses services vers trappes le
lieu est inoccupé un projet de maison de
retraite et dans les cartons il semble
avancer plutôt bien
à presque 150 ans le château de La
Coudre pourrait bien s'offrir une
seconde vie après avoir accueilli la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin la commune de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux s'est portée
candidate pour transformer cette demeure
en EHPAD cette candidature trouve sa
cause dans les migrations des inondins
aujourd'hui une partie des personnes
retraitées des ménages intra-muros
passant d'un pavillon à un appartement
de là est né l'idée d'une résidence
service accompagnant un EHPAD cette
installation sera divisée en deux
parties les services administratifs et
sociaux seront installés dans le château
l'autre partie la résidence service
dédiée aux personnes plus autonomes sera
construite à l'entrée du site la
capacité de l'accueil donc de la
résidence service et environ une
soixantaine de logements et les pâtes
donc sera de 84 lits 80 en hébergement
complet et 4 lits à temps à hébergement
partiel c'est-à-dire des hébergements
temporaires soit pour permettre du répit
soit un retour d'hôpital pour
accompagner les personnes une convention
devrait être signée avec l'hôpital de
plaisir pour prendre en charge les
personnes âgées devant être
hospitalisées le seul point
d'interrogation réside dans la présence
ou non d'autres projets pour le site du
château de La Coudre dont le parc sera
toujours ouvert au public Simoncini
remporte l'appel d'offres du conseil
général l'EHPAD pourrait ouvrir ses
portes fin 2014
l'école Victor Hugo au Clayes-sous-Bois
sera bien reconstruite le chantier est
en cours cette école avait été incendiée
souvenez-vous il y a quelques années les
élèves vont pouvoir redécouvrir leur
nouvel établissement normalement la
rentrée prochaine les explications
Valéry Auribeau et Elodie moine
l'école Victor Hugo aux Clayes-sous-Bois
René doucement de ses cendres à la
rentrée prochaine les 194 élèves
pourront réintégrer les locaux
totalement reconstruits les travaux
démarré l'ouverture est prévue pour la
rentrée prochaine et cette ouverture
donc de l'école va de pair avec la
restructuration du quartier en avril
2010 un incendie avait ravagé l'école
primaire et susciter une vive émotion
les enfants avaient temporairement été
réunis dans des algeco sur le site de
l'école Jean Jaurès pour cette
reconstruction la mairie a souhaité
mettre l'accent sur l'apport de lumière
et notamment via la future bibliothèque
entièrement vitrée et tournée vers
l'extérieur la structure désormais
totalement désamiée sera en bois et en
acier avec une isolation par l'extérieur
pour un aspect complètement différent et
moderne coût total de l'opération 4
millions et demi d'euros la renaissance
de l'école primaire passe également par
la réhabilitation complète du quartier
de poivre une réhabilitation qui a
démarré la semaine dernière avec
l'inauguration du terrain de football
synthétique à terme le quartier verra la
création d'une aire de jeux la réfection
des abords de l'école la création des
parkings autour de la piscine ainsi que
l'aménagement de jardin familiaux
musique à présent avant de passer aux
années 80 au reste bien dans l'année
2012 avec ce groupe Lily sofa en concert
ce vendredi 26 octobre à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse portrait de ce
groupe avec Johanna Soudry
Sophie vitam au repas elle compose texte
et Mélodie depuis plusieurs années et
son tour d'autres musiciens pour former
le groupe Lilly sofar Alexandre de mon
repas s'occupe des arrangements Franck
originaire de Trappes joue de la guitare
quant à JB est également des Yvelines il
est percussionniste et s'intéresse au
beau drame un instrument irlandais
folk pour le les guitares acoustiques la
référence à un instrument ancien que la
vie et la roue et puis sinon ça reste ça
reste pop c'est de la chanson c'est
assez frais la chanson goldilox qui
signifie Boucle d'Or en français
s'inspire directement du compte je
pensais à ce compte de boucles d'or
boucles d'or et les trois ours sa petite
fille qui trouve pas bien sa place entre
entre le père la mère et l'en fant et
puis en fait en baladant il y avait un
rythme qui venait et c'est aussi pour ça
que cette chanson est uniquement
rythmique et voix je voyais pas du tout
une musique dessus je vois les ombres
qui dansent
dans ton regard immense
qui me hante
me tourmente les ombres c'était une
chanson un peu bizarre en fait qui est
venue suite à une sorte de rêve ou
plutôt de cauchemar j'avais j'avais ce
light motif les ombres les ombres qui me
trottaient dans la tête et puis un jour
j'étais un peu énervée je jouais avec un
peu de rage sans trop faire attention à
la technique il y avait des harmoniques
qui venaient et petit à petit à ce riff
un peu un peu d'un peu tellurique un peu
aussi très cyclique qui venait et puis
les paroles sont venues dessus
illisofar se produira vendredi 26
octobre à Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse au
théâtre cafards l'album du groupe n'est
pas encore commercialisé mais Sophie le
propose au public lors de ses concerts
et sur Internet
voilà pour Lili so far et je vous
l'annoncer en début d'émissions la suite
du 7 8 est consacrée à stars 80 la
nouvelle comédie de Thomas Langmann le
producteur de l'oscarisés The artistes
direction le multiplex de 50 ans en
Yvelines où l'équipe du film était
présente pour rencontrer le public mardi
soir